You’re a child. Awake at night. What a feeling.
In your room, you cling to these rare hours of
the evening and watch the hour hand crawl closer
toward the parts of the clock you’ve never seen
touched. Now, you stare out your window embracing
the moon, the stars, and the darkness that engulfs
them. You trace an owl’s hoo-hoos up toward
the densest evergreen in the neighborhood.
You see a rat scurry across the top of a brick
wall. You wave to your new nocturnal friends,
bonded by the preference of night.
Now, you open your window and inhale,
smelling the dark sky like chocolate
cake. You hold it in as long as you can.
Very soon, you know, it
will all be taken from you.
Not by a god or a black hole or any other of the
Universe’s hypothesized collapses. At this age,
you know nothing of physical cosmology. You know
nothing of the Book of Revelation. You’re just
a child. The forces that give and take from you
are not understood through physics nor philosophy,
not through numbers nor thought experiments.
Look at you. Your thumb is still pruned from
having just kicked the habit of sucking it. Your
pajamas are still one unified piece of clothing,
cradling your entirety with
fuzzy cotton. Your Teddy Bear
is still an extension of your
arm, not yet removed by maturity.
You’re still another fifteen years from believing
your life is dictated by astrological signs or
personal freewill or mathematical outputs. It’s
not that you’re ignorant. In fact, you’re quite
bright as a child. You don’t bother to comprehend
the forces outside your house, because you know,
as long as you are living inside it, they have no
governance. The only true rule comes from within,
from the two gods you have seen with your very
own eyes, sitting on the ripped sofa in grey
sweatpants watching a show about rich people
drinking mimosas on boats in the Mediterranean.
The almighty parents. Rulers of everything. And
with just one compound word called up the stairs,
they have the power to take
everything away from you. “Bedtime!”
And suddenly the curtains are
pulled over the world you long for.
Now it’s not the stars but the ceiling
you’re staring at. But, thankfully,
you are not alone. You pull your Teddy Bear
out from its hibernation beneath your armpit,
and you hug him gently, careful not to squeeze
out his stuffing. Laying there, you can’t help
but wonder how your bear got like this, so
beaten and bruised. Torn up like a dog toy.
One eye dangling from a string. His left
leg bends forward, impersonating the joint
structures of a flamingo. Yet, as far as you
know, your best pal has done nothing but sleep.
How is he so battered? Can hibernation be that
taxing? Do Teddy Bears expire? The questions,
for now, must be ignored. You lay there together
in your bed fighting the feeling of slumber,
almost as if rebelling against mom
and dad’s tyranny. Thinking deeply
only makes you sleepier. And
tonight, you insist on staying awake.
It’s nine-thirty and you’ve
yet to be sucked into a dream,
and that in itself is a small victory. But your
parents’ wishes will not be evaded that easily,
if ever. They fight back by turning on the
air conditioning. The soft, rhythmic humming
of the white noise weighs on your eyes, and
soon you can’t resist it any longer. Sleep
sneaks up on you. The battle is lost. A safe
ten minutes later, your parents poke their
heads into your room and see your body stiff
and motionless, wrapped in sheets like a mummy.
They celebrate their victory with a quick
kiss and go back to the sofa to rest like
gods on the seventh day. And while you
are sleeping, dreaming of a tomorrow where
you don’t surrender to the same powers,
there is yet another battle to be fought.
And if all goes well…you’ll
sleep right through it.
But some children won’t be so lucky.
On 07/07/2001, a Portland, Oregon news
headline reported a young boy missing from home
in the middle of the night. His parents were
quick to respond that their son wasn’t the type
of boy to go wandering out into the dark and that
something suspicious was sure to be discovered
there in his bedroom. The first thing noticed
was his stuffed animal, a jovial orca, torn to
shreds, its stuffing scattered across the carpet.
Its head and body were stationed in the corner
nearest the bed, soaked in a black substance,
similar to ink. Its eyes damp with water.
The boy, however, was not to be found. As
the parents held their son’s dismantled orca in
their hands, feeling the weight of mortality,
they combed their fingers through the stuffed
animal organs, as if giving it an impromptu
autopsy, trying to determine what kind of
beast could have done this. But it wasn’t
justice for the orca that they were after.
By the time we are old enough to be parents,
we have outgrown empathy for our inanimate
counterparts. For them, the orca was simply
a representation of the cruel fate that
may also have been bestowed on their child;
its death was only respected for how it related
to the living. And so the poor orca was set aside,
forgotten about until investigators
called upon The Foundation to intervene,
at which point, MTF Iota-12 were dispatched.
It was revealed that the young boy’s room had
large trails of viscous black
liquid streaking the walls,
the very same liquid found on the orca.
But where did this liquid come from?
Unfortunately, there was no camera footage to
give us the answer. Neither were there eyewitness
reports or any residual signs of what specifically
occurred. Neighbors who were awake reported
hearing the thump, thump, thumping from the room,
which as expected was useless bystander insight,
leading to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations. Maybe it was an extremely
localized earthquake. Maybe he was just throwing
a temper tantrum. But where does maybe this,
maybe that lead us to? Can factual answers
ever come from this level of uncertainty?
Well, one specific “Maybe” just may be the
key to cracking this case. Let me explain.
Two days after the event, the child was
rediscovered, unconscious behind a hedge
in the family’s garden. A brief interview
revealed that the child witnessed the final
minutes of what he described as an intense battle.
He claimed, “My orca was fighting a big monster,
and then the monster grabbed me and took
me out the window, but someone saw it,
so it dropped me, and I hid in the bush.”
A second interview revealed no other discoveries,
but the child claimed that the monster
ate his socks. Initial reactions to the
two interviews were as expected. Adults reasoned
the claims were imaginary, a fabrication of the
child’s mind manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured actually was.
But heard beneath the skeptical murmurs of jaded
grown-ups enslaved by their narrow perceptions
was one individual who dared to suggest: “Maybe,
just maybe… the boy is telling the truth.”
And it was in the spirit of this hopeful
and trusting “maybe” that The Foundation
would prove the boy’s story to be of truth.
And the truth would be known as SCP-6330.
SCP-6330 is a phenomenon affecting stuffed
animals worldwide, though is most common
in Teddy Bears. Manifestation of this phenomenon
is referred to as a Sleepwalker Event, occurring
only within the households of families with young
children, typically between the ages of 1 to 14.
While you’re asleep, vulnerable to
what lingers awake, your favorite
stuffed animal may find life impulsively to
combat entities referred to as SCP-6330-2.
These creatures typically blend with shadows,
though this mechanism is poorly understood.
They somewhat resemble creatures associated
with fantasy, such as dragons or ogres,
always manifesting beneath your bed, no
matter how messy or clean it might be.
SCP-6330-2 instances depict behavior indicating
that they intend to hunt or prey upon the sleeping
child. And it isn’t nightlights or security
systems that stop them, but rather SCP-6330-1s.
SCP-6330-1 are stuffed animals already present in
a child’s room that seem to be non-anomalous prior
to SCP-6330-2 manifestations. SCP-6330-1 has been
shown to instantaneously manifest small wooden
weaponry in order to combat SCP-6330-2 to protect
their child. Battles have been shown to last
upwards of 20 minutes and are always near silent.
There is an unspoken agreement between both sides
to keep their history concealed as best they can.
In observed cases, SCP-6330-1 have emerged
victorious, though are severely ‘wounded’ during
the skirmish. Torn wool and stuffing are common,
and following all known events, SCP-6330-1
have “died” due to their injuries, but only
after sacrificing themselves for the safety of
the child. Prior to “death,” the instance will
drag the SCP-6330-2’s corpse back under the
bed frame and demanifest. To understand this,
the Foundation has conducted just one test. Given
the volatile nature of recreating the events,
the Foundation did not push their luck
with subsequent studies. And so it’s the
lone research done in 1987 on Site-44 that they
still lean on to this day to understand SCP-6330
and the instances that come with it.
It began with a researcher volunteering his
7-year-old daughter - henceforth referred to as
‘subject’ - to be placed in a humanoid containment
room and soothed to sleep using a Teddy Bear
that she had a strong emotional attachment
to. For 12 straight tests, our subject was
observed to sleep through the night peacefully,
her environment remaining in alignment with
the trivialities of deep sleep. But on the
13th study, something would happen. Something very
unsettling. Even for The Foundation’s standards.
MTF Iota-12 were stationed at the room’s entrance
for swift intervention if needed, and until that
13th attempt, they felt their focus to be
pointless. Approaching the 3rd hour, however,
they felt a subtle and unexplainable value in
their presence. They felt something coming on.
That feeling when danger is looming. That feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in case. And
just as they made eye contact with one another to
acknowledge this shared feeling within the group,
a quiet rustling sound was heard beneath
the bed, and sounds reminiscent of a large
animal’s breathing became audible.
Suddenly, a pair of large, scaly-clawed
hands grasped the rim of the bed frame. A
creature resembling a western dragon emerged.
But was it actually a dragon? Were the sheets
ready to be blasted to flames? If slain would
the necks regrow and multiply by the hundreds?
These thoughts raced through MTF Iota-12’s head.
One member instinctually ran for the door
to go protect the child, but he was held
back and restrained, reminded that the success
of the experiment was dependent on letting the
situation play out naturally. He was hard to
console. Patience at this moment did not feel
like a virtue. It felt irresponsible. A creature
standing approximately 3 meters above the ground,
switching between bipedal and quadrupedal
motion, was stalking a sleeping child,
and they were instructed simply to watch.
For five minutes, the SCP-6330-2 patrolled the
room, moving silently and methodically, unaware of
the surveillance cameras. Then SCP-6330-2 turned
towards the subject, positioning itself at the
foot of the bed, stretching its arms out towards
the subject. It gaped its jaws wide, exposing rows
of large, pointed teeth and a dark pink tongue. It
looked like a snake in a field of mice.
As it prepared to lunge at the subject,
MTF Iota-12 was ready to intervene, but before
they could, the stuffed bear stood up on the
subject’s chest, and drew a small sword and
shield from an unknown source, almost magically,
like switching weapons in an old Zelda video game.
It positioned its sword’s tip downward and held
its shield at its side. SCP-6330-1 hunched over
slightly and twirled its sword, maintaining eye
contact with SCP-6330-2 the entire way through.
After 10 seconds, the SCP-6330-2 throws its jaws
at the subject and SCP-6330-1 responds with a
leap towards the subject’s attacker, slicing
SCP-6330-2’s eye. The SCP-6330-2 responds with a
quiet grunt and touches its wound, which leaks a
viscous black liquid. The SCP-6330-1 jumps towards
SCP-6330-2 and, mid-battle, uses fabric from the
bedsheets to quickly stitch the wound, attempting
to minimize mess and proof of its presence.
Both instances went to battle for 9 minutes before
the first signs of damage to SCP-6330-1. Following
the severing of one of SCP-6330-2’s dorsal spikes,
it strikes the SCP-6330-1 with a heavy slap,
which sends SCP-6330-1 across the room. SCP-6330-1
stands back up, placing a hand on its stomach,
and looks at its hand which is now
covered in wool and stuffing.
They charge at each other once again, but
as the subject moves slightly in her sleep,
both instances stop and quickly agree on peace
until the subject settles. When that happens,
the instances resume fighting. Research notes that
while the battle is genuine, there is an element
of guidance. They do not follow a script, but it
appears they follow a code. While both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the other,
neither wants it broadcasted to the public.
After 20 minutes of battle, both instances are
heavily scarred and injured. After kicking itself
off of the SCP-6330-2’s nose, SCP-6330-1 sprints
from one side of the room towards SCP-6330-2,
leaping into the air and landing a fatal
blow, slicing the neck of the other instance,
which falls lifeless to the floor. SCP-6330-2 is
dragged by the SCP-6330-1, back under the bed.
A short while later, the SCP-6330-1 emerges.
Damage sustained includes loss of one buttoned
eye, exposed stuffing, and torn wool.
It places its sword and broken shield
on a nearby nightstand. SCP-6330-1 then drags
itself up the bedsheets towards the subject,
who was sleeping peacefully throughout the test.
It rests beside the child, lying motionless.
It seems to glare directly at the camera, and a
small digit protrudes from its round hand, giving
a ‘thumbs up’ to researchers. Its head flops
onto the child’s cheek before it ceases to move.
The father who risked his daughter for research
is pleased with the discoveries regarding both
anomalies, but it brings about a new set
of questions concerning children and their
relationship with the dark. These very thoughts
you might even wonder yourself. Maybe a kid’s
desire to stay up past bedtime isn’t so much about
wanting to watch cartoons with curse words or read
Calvin and Hobbes. Maybe it’s not about a desire
to be awake at all, but rather a subconscious fear
of being asleep. Maybe our senses as children are
heightened to the anomalies that creep about.
Maybe all the fabled fears of children aren’t
fairytales after all. And maybe mom and dad
checking under our bed is just performance
parenting, because even if something were there,
would they even be able to see it? Or is
everything beyond an adult’s understanding
misattributed to the imagination? As we age,
does our perception of how reality should look
alter the reality that is actually there.
Do we indeed see clearer with our expensive
glasses from our high-rise office space, or
did we see more accurately in the glow of
our action figure night light, spying through
stitches in our blankets, looking past crusty
eye boogers at what moved in the shadows?
It is hard to ever know. For every real encounter
a child has with an SCP-6330, there might be
hundreds of falsehoods. The ratio is impossible
to calculate. But as long as Teddy Bears are
universal, so too are their anomalous enemies.
And so where does that fact leave us? How do we go
forward? Should we be afraid to put our children
to sleep? Afraid of the monsters under their bed?
I don’t think that’s what our hero would want.
Sometimes we have to learn to trust
things, even if we don’t understand them.
Like gravity or multiplication. We have to
trust that the relationship between children
and their stuffed animals are in fact real. We
have to relearn that loyalty is reciprocated,
even if the adult world has taught us otherwise.
And if we ever need a reminder of these lessons,
we can look to Event 184, in Cambridge, England,
where we have our first recording of a Sleepwalker
Event outside of controlled testing – and also,
our first piece of evidence proving SCP-6330-1 to
understand language and how to use it to connect
with humans in ways beyond being cute and cuddly.
On 19/11/2008, a call was filed
to local authorities by a family
who claimed to have discovered footage of a
Sleepwalker Event within their son’s room.
Mobile Task Force Iota-12 ‘Lucid Dreamers’ were
dispatched to investigate. Immediately, the
footage was seized by personnel and all members of
the family were administered Class-A amnestics.
The child’s bed sways lightly as an instance of
SCP-6330-2 emerges. The instance resembles an
unknown creature, though is described as having a
large, muscular frame. The instance walks to the
opposite end of the room, hunching over and
observing the child for exactly 10 minutes.
As the SCP-6330-2 begins to stand further
upright, it extends a retractable set of claws.
Then the child’s Teddy Bear suddenly
stands, drawing a bow and quiver.
SCP-6330-2 assumes a quadrupedal stance
and snarls before lunging towards the bed.
The SCP-6330-1 fires a single
arrow towards the SCP-6330-2,
striking the instance directly in its canine-like
snout. SCP-6330-2 responds with a loud huff,
reminiscent of that of a bull or bovine.
The instances battle for approximately 30 minutes,
the longest recorded Sleepwalker Event to date.
Both show abilities and skill sets consistent with
other SCP-6330-1 and -2 instances. Eventually,
SCP-6300-2 has SCP-6330-1 pinned to a nearby wall
and tries to strangle it. The SCP-6330-2 then
pulls one of SCP-6330-1’s arrows from its arm,
plunging it into the -1’s chest. Then
the SCP-6330-2 leans its head towards
SCP-6330-1 and whispers into the instance’s
right ear, though audio recordings cannot
determine exactly what was vocalized.
The SCP-6330-1 lifts up its head,
staring blankly into SCP-6330-2’s eyes. It
reaches behind its back, pulling out a small,
entirely wooden Glock-19 handgun. The bear
points the weapon into SCP-6330-2’s forehead
and fires. The shot is silent and the SCP-6330-2’s
body falls limp. Black, viscous fluid sprays on
the wall. The SCP-6330-1 hauls SCP-6330-2’s corpse
towards the bed, noticeably limping. It drags the
body by its large forearm and demanifests
upon reaching the underneath of the bed.
SCP-6330-1 returns, and briefly stares
around the room before turning to the child.
It climbs up a desk and finds a piece of paper
and pen. It goes on to write the following note:
“Hello, Timothy.
Thank you for always taking care of
me, it really was fun. I was able
to repay the favor of protecting you.
Unfortunately, I am hurt. I need to go,
I’m too weak to stay and I
just hope you’ll remember me.
It’s been fun helping you. I’ve enjoyed
my time under your care. Going into this,
I knew it would happen; the Sleepwalkers coming
for you. I’m just happy I could do my job.
Goodbye, my friend.
I hope I may see you soon.”
Now go check out “SCP-999
and the Most Wholesome SCPs”
and “Top 14 Friendliest SCP” for more
anomalies that’ll just warm your heart!